[Music]
chrisan
for
[Music]
in
for for
Christian
[Music]
granted it looks great when we're not on
here you know
[Music]
thank you appreciate a little response
little call and response um Welcome to
our uh table service tonight um hello
online friends it's nice to see y'all
too even though I don't see you but I
know you're there um couple of
announcements as we get started tonight
um there is a relationship event um if
you want to improve your relationship
with a significant other regardless of
your relationship status join us for a
workshop focused on enhancing
communication skills and navigating
personal Dynamics our hope is that
through self-discovery and practical
tools you can learn how to build a
stronger partnership
you can RSVP by scanning the QR code for
free child care is available for anyone
who
RSVPs also of note uh Easter Service is
right around the corner our Easter
Service this year will be Saturday
once's get Saturday that's in big bold
letters in my announcements that part
April 19th um at 5:00 p.m. so we hope
you will join us then to celebrate uh
the Risen Christ with our service and
joining us for a family meal immediately
after at the Family Life Center next
door everyone is
welcome uh accessibility bucket if you
are anxious about being in service
tonight or the sech uh Church setting um
or a part of the disability Community
are just feeling fidgety um please know
we have an accessibility Bucket over to
my
left um there are noise cancelling
headphones fidgets coloring sheets we
ask you return them to the bucket at the
end of service
um and then as we begin to transition
like to remind you the candles that
we've lit tonight are a sign of the
presence of Christ Among Us fully Divine
and fully
human so as we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and
simplicity Sacred Space a place for
prayer worship and adoration a place to
behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
your grace to find you to mend your
heart may we all come
home thanks Jared would you guys stand
with us as we get started in worship
tonight and we just invite you into this
space so bring everything that you
walked in with tonight bring um bring
your troubles bring your worries bring
your happiness and your celebrations and
we just want to hold those together
before God who is a foundation for us
who is our source and our starting point
and our beginning and our home so we're
going to start tonight with Jesse you
guys just follow
along Christ is my firm foundation
The Rock on which I stand when
everything around me is
[Music]
Shen I've never been more glad that I
put my faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me down he's
faithful through
[Music]
generations so I would he feel
now he
won't no he won't no he
won't I still got joy in
ch I've got peace that makes no sense so
I won't be going
under I'm not held by my Own St cuz I
build my life on
Jesus and he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he fa
now
[Music]
he he w
he won't
fail he won't
fail he
won sing it again he
won't you won't
fail he won't
fail Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I
stand everything around me
Shen i'
never more than and I put my faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me down he's
faithful through
Generations so why would he fail
now he
W he
W he won't
fail he won't
fail he w
[Music]
winds blw my house is built high
you and I safe with you I'm going to
make get through sing that again rain
came
when my house is built on
you and I am safe with you I'm going to
make it through
came with blue my house was built on
you I'm safe with you I'm going to make
it yeah I'm going to make it
through I'm standing strong on you yeah
going to make it
through my house was built on you Christ
is my fir
[Music]
Foundation The Rock on which I stand
everything around me
Shing I'm never been
more I put my faith in Jes
Jesus cuz he's never let me down
faithful through
generations so why would he fa
now
[Music]
he all right kiddos y'all are dismissed
to go to your
classes thank you kids ministry team so
much for loving on them showing them the
love of
Jesus and as they leave we're going to
transition into the prayers of the
people you guys can follow along and
read the parts in red together
aloud Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable
the marginalized and those unjustly
targeted for their gender sexuality race
or other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to you God
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen we suffered all kinds of
grief tasted a bitter cup of
deep out of the bitter comes something
sweet our faith more preious than
gold we been tested by so many
FS burned in the heat of what I hope
free find us here singing in a foolish
chir of faith more precious than
gold our faith more precious than
[Music]
go though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in
[Music]
everything there is a secret we can only
know walk through places we don't want
to
go in the we learn the song
of our faith more precious than
gold our faith more precious than
gold though we don't see you we love
you when we don't Fe
you we still
see we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in
[Applause]
Everything Jesus in
everything Tears On The
Altar from all we've
lost following you no matter what it
call
maybe a
whisper maybe a roar this is the sound
of those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you
Lord Tears On The
Altar from all we've
lost following you no matter what it
cost
maybe a
whisper May a roar this is the sound of
those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you
Lord we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
see we've got a
reason to trust
you Jesus in
everything we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still see
you we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in everything
Jesus in
[Music]
Everything Jesus in
everything Tears On The
Altar from all we've
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper maybe a rock
this is the sound of those who love you
Lord this is the sound of those who love
youy
[Music]
of
could all the praise
coulding wory of every breath could Brea
live
[Music]
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could
ever worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for
you sing out
holy
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love To those
[Music]
s
worthy worthy of every song we could
ever
sing worthy of all the praise we could
evering worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for
you live
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could
ever worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for
you we live for
you
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes and
wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love to
those around me
[Music]
and I will build my life
upon your love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in in
you
alone and I will not be
Shen and I will build my
life upon your love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in in
you
Al and I will not be
Shen
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me
with your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
To those are around me and I will build
my life of upon your love it is
a
foundation and I will put my trust in in
you
alone it I will not be
Shen
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes
and show me who you are in
me with your heart
and in love to
those around
me God thank you for being our
[Music]
leader the director of our
steps the light unto our path
God as I think about the journey that so
many of us have walked to get to where
we are
today it's not
easy to
follow it's not always
smooth it's a journey of sacrifice
it's a lesson of laying your life down
over and over and over again because we
trust that in losing our life to you God
that is where we find our hope that is
where we find true
love that is where we find
ourselves as a child of God
God help us to keep
following even when the road is
hard and when the light is
dim and our hearts are
broken God would we hear your voice
calling us forward would we feel your
warmth and your presence surrounding us
with
Grace with
purpose knowing that our hope is in
you our life is in
you would we trust that you are a good
God who is up to a good work in
us I just keep hearing that verse in the
Bible go through my head as we've been
singing tonight do not let your hearts
be troubled for I Am With You
do not let your hearts be troubled for I
am with
you do not let your hearts be troubled
for I Am with
[Music]
You Jesus we hang on to that promise
we trust that you will walk this path
with
us we trust that there are good things
up
ahead thank you for being
faithful each step of the
way it's in your name that we pray these
things tonight amen
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you and say hello and then we'll
get started with our message and you can
be seated
all right there I am Grace and peace so
good to be with yall so so good uh my
name is Brett and uh I'm the pastor here
my pronouns are he him and um yeah it's
just a joy joy to be with you and uh to
welcome you into uh into this space so
um can youall give it up for the worship
team that was like a beautiful beautiful
set
um and also our Tech team has been doing
so much we you can see where got these
speakers last week they are here and
other rays and we're like trying to mess
with it so if there's you know some
issues and things that's because we're
trying to to work out all the uh the
sound stuff so um yeah at any rate I am
yeah I'm really really glad to to be
here in this space um with you all and
and to welcome you and that includes
those join us online um y'all are not
forgotten and um anyone here tonight who
is new um thanks so much for um being
here being here with us so um you want
me to step back onto the stage would
that be better would it maybe
help I'll try that Get Behind these
speakers see if that that works is that
a little better no I'm just driving all
crazy it's okay so um let's see so we
are uh we're in the season of lint right
now and uh this is a I'm just going to
keep SC by the end of the message I'll
be back there I'm just goingon to that's
like my strategy like maybe it'll help
um uh so this is like a 40-day time of
of really just heart and mind um
preparation as we uh approach Good
Friday that's the day of the Cross and
then um onto Easter for us like Jared
mentioned Saturday and um so this uh so
during this time we follow the
lectionary um so kind of the prescribe
you know scriptures and such um that the
the church kind of sets out and so
um with that in mind the title of my
message tonight is the walls we build
the walls we build and our primary
scripture it's going to be on the screen
so you can read along it's 2 Corinthians
chapter 5 uh verses 16-
21 so from now on WE regard no one from
a worldly point of view though we once
regarded Christ in this way we do so no
longer therefore if anyone is in Christ
the new creation has come the old has
gone the new is here all this is from
God who reconciled us to himself through
Christ and gave us the ministry of
reconciliation that God was reconciling
the world to himself in Christ not
counting people's sins against them and
he has committed to us the message of
reconciliation we are therefore Christ's
ambassadors it's as though God were
making his appeal through us we implore
you on Christ's behalf be reconciled to
God God made him who had no sin to be
sin for us so that in him we might
become the righteousness of
God so I find that uh that opening line
uh really insightful verse 16 so from
now on WE regard no one from a worldly
point of view so from the the kind of
broader context text of 2 Corinthians
chapter uh 5 we know that um kind of
that in essence people um are much more
than meets the eye like in essence we
are not only you know a a flesh and
blood kind of body um but we are in fact
a spiritual body called in times or in
Past Times uh a soul though I kind of
like the language of spiritual body
because we tend did well whenever I say
soul people imagine I don't know like a
little orb of light or something within
them you know um have even heard there's
sort of like atheist theist debates
online where um folks like will be like
well we've research we've we've cut open
bodies and we've never found the soul
you know it's like as though it's this
you know it's like this thing so um and
we often kind of contrast it to a body
you know like you're not a body you're a
soul you know and then gets weird it's
like whole anti-body stuff there like a
whole Road you go down so that's where I
like this language of uh spiritual body
right in other words you might say there
is a there's something of God there's
something Divine there's something uh
kind of spiritual um about you this
spiritual body and uh that's why we've
all had this experience right of
observing a a dead body perhaps even
someone uh you loved you know like a
viewing or a funeral or something and
and it's a strange experience to see
someone's like physical body with their
spiritual body
departed you know it's a Str it's like
you just have this weird sense of like
where did they go they're not there
somehow they are gone it's a but of
course then there they are it's a it's a
it's a weird thing right so that's where
you get this this kind of dichotomy or
um this kind of reality of the the
physical body and then this this kind of
spiritual body um but of course that's
also why the reverse is true um like
what a miracle it is to look at someone
and see like they
aliveness their Spirit their soul right
it's it's there I had this uh uh
interesting um kind of little experiment
this or not experiment but experience a
few weeks back we were all in uh the van
like driving somewhere
and it wasn't just my nuclear family it
was like my kind of extended family of
nieces and nephew and all that so we're
all kind of piled in the in the Odyssey
the Honda Odyssey and uh my niece just
kind of pipes up I think it was sort of
one of those like when you're bored
driving you know and maybe I don't know
maybe no one had their screens or
something so she just pipes up with this
like kind of random car question maybe
you've had this experience someone like
just you know just trying to fill the
time and so my asked uh what is your
favorite characteristic about people
and we needed some clarifying questions
so we like well what do you mean like is
it you're thinking like personality or
like physical characteristics she said
physical characteristics what what is
your favorite uh characteristic about
people and so of course everyone you
know is like chiming in with their
answers like skin or this or that you
know whatever and uh then but there was
one answer that that like kept coming up
over and over and
over um any guesses as to
the eyes yeah and uh and there's that
old saying about the eyes right the the
eyes or or what they're a window to the
to the soul right to the the spirit I
mean it's just it's no wonder that we
favorite thing you know and we tell a
lot from people by their eyes and and
that's where we sense their attention
and their you know their their kind of
their aliveness um with us so thus kind
of um part of what it means then right
if you kind of reverse that to regard
someone uh only from a as Paul puts it a
a kind of worldly point of view um what
is that it's to in essence kind of
ignore this spiritual Dimension so to
speak right it's to kind of reduce them
to their their either their physical
body or you know or something about them
a certain personality trait or their
kind of beliefs or their group grp
Identity or some other characteristic
some you know gender or sexual
orientation or something to kind of just
reduce them to that thing right and when
we do this um the often unintended
though sometimes intended but often
unintended side effect of this um is
basically we start to distance ourselves
from from
them um and this plays out when we're in
conflict with people we might say that
one of the major Temptations when I'm in
conflict with someone or it could be a
group right a group of someone is in
essence it's to do what it's to reduce
them to label them even to kind of
dehumanize them in these way where we
start to regard them from this worldly
point of view you know oh we have these
labels you know oh he's he's such a
narcissist you know um she's just always
so emotional he's what an indag
3 you know how those those we can even
get political you know those liberal
snowflakes those uh conservative sheeple
you know how they are you know and then
it gets religious you know Muslims oh
those
extremists Christians all those
Hypocrites you know the the Godless
atheist hedonists or whatever like we
just have these you know these kind of
labels and and such right and in essence
um this becomes a kind of lazy way out
because what does it do I mean why does
it feel so good and does you know
because it kind of automatically
justifies me you know in my
self-righteousness right this this
posture of reducing labeling
dehumanizing and just generally viewing
them um what happens it's it's viewing
them from a worldly kind of point of
view but here in 2 Corinthians chapter 5
what's Paul doing I think he's calling
us higher he he's inviting us to elevate
the
conversation how by elevating our
seeing perceiving folks from a spiritual
point of view which is to recognize
right that just like you they too are
offshoots of the Divine Psalm 82 uh
verse 6 comes to mind I say the psalmist
writes you are Gods notice the lowercase
G there right so it's not saying you are
the almighty God you know but it's but
it's you are you were Gods you're you're
you're offshoots of you're you're all
children of the most high the Christian
writer CS Lewis put this really
beautifully he said it's a serious thing
to live in a society of possible gods
and
goddesses to remember that the dullest
most uninteresting person you can talk
to May one day be a creature which if
you saw it now you would be strongly
tempted to
worship There Are No Ordinary People you
have never talked to a mere mortal
Nations cultures Arts
civilizations these are mortal and their
life is to ours as the life of aat but
it is
Immortals whom we joke with work with
marry snub and
exploit so where does Paul kind of take
this Insight well he ends up kind of
hooking it up to uh in essence the the
call of God on our lives Verse 18 again
and we'll read through verse 20 all this
is from God who reconciled us to himself
through Christ and then did what and
gave us the ministry of
reconciliation that God was reconciling
the world to himself in Christ not
counting people's sins against them and
he has committed to us the message of
reconciliation we are therefore Christ's
ambassadors it's as though God were
making his very appeal through us we
implore you he writes on Christ's behalf
be reconciled to God you see when we
regard people other people from this
worldly point of view we we distance
ourselves from them and their
failures and then it allows us to tell a
story a story about their
guilt and our
innocence and this often gets very
extreme right they are nothing this is
the reducing again right they are no
good sorry so and so and you wouldn't
believe the depths of depravity to which
they've sunk and you wouldn't believe
the Injustice that they've perpetuated
it's awful it's you know it's shocking
it's
inhuman and there may be a lot lot of
Truth in that but you can feel when we
do it in that kind of reducing
dehumanizing way you can feel the the
distancing
happening
and that but of course the truth is that
like step one of the Gospel El is the
recognition not so much at first that
they are sinners you know which is true
enough but it's it's actually a
recognition first like well well I
am and I I've said this many times
before you know to say I'm a sinner it
doesn't mean I'm like intrinsically evil
and there's nothing good in me or
something you know um it just means that
I too have done awful things you know I
too have Hur
and exploited I too have done
evil so the acknowledgement that
actually I am a sinner in need of the
Forgiveness of God it starts to crumble
the walls I'm thinking the walls of
resentment the walls of hostility that I
build between myself and those who have
hurt
me had a conversation a few years ago
with a uh a fellow Christian and and
this at a previous church and uh they
were actually a leader kind of in the
community and we we were talking kind of
processing this repentance forgiveness
you know kind of
themes and um I could tell and talking
with them they had really been they'
been hurt um in the past they didn't get
into details you know but they had they
had been hurt and uh at one point in the
conversation they looked at me and they
said well here's the thing I just want
you to know that I will never ever
forgive
them I'm I'm a
Christian but I've got a memory like an
elephant and once someone crosses me
uhuh you know like no way and uh I I
sense you know there was so much pain
behind that I didn't like feel the need
to well that's you know um just a moment
to listen you know but I was definitely
I was thinking like well I know I hear
you but that is a really strange thing
for a Christian like like to say you
know um there's a famous question in
Matthew 18 by the disciple Peter when he
asks Jesus uh how many times should I
forgive someone who wrongs
me and it's a really good question and
actually Peter kind of cautiously
Ventures an answer he's like seven times
and which is that's a lot I don't know
you ever had to forgive someone just
over you know I mean it's like oh my God
seven times is a lot and uh if you've if
you can do quick math well Jesus answer
I should say is uh he of course comes
back says no not seven 70 times seven so
if you can do that math or if you've
seen Veggie Tales if you're a kid
girlriend VG Tales I did SM then you
know 490 I don't even remember that
character I think it was a little
asparagus and veg tailes anyway it
doesn't matter um was it Junior
Asparagus oh that's right that just came
to me I just um right in for so that's
his answer right which in essence is I
mean I don't think he means that
literally so at 491 you're off the hook
you know U obviously the the kind of
heart intention there is basically look
as Christians our um at least our our
forgiveness we might call it our
reconciling heart um simply knows no
bounds or limits like in essence because
we are the forgiven people in Christ we
then become the forgiving people right
and that's just like the logic of
Christian Theology and practice and uh
it's at this point though I know there's
plenty of folks getting real nervous um
that I should mention there is a a
difference between forgiveness and
Reconciliation uh forgiveness is always
this is this can always be our work when
we're the the person who's been hurt you
this is something that's between us and
God and um and that's yeah that's
something God can kind of do um in and
through us uh reconciliation is
different that takes the the repentance
of the
perpetrator um and that's really
important and that would even add trust
is even separate from those two as well
right because even just because you
reconcile with someone doesn't
necessarily mean like we're besties you
know I mean or oh it just back just like
old times you I mean sometimes it can be
that you know um but it's a process you
know it's a process and forever the
relationship may be different um right
and there's even uh boundaries and such
right I think this is really key to
mention especially in cases of like
really intense like abuse um trauma
things like that it's where we have to
be really careful of of kind of uh
conflating all of these you know oh
forgive just forgive real quick and and
Rec and then we kind of oh that means
reconcile that means be all good and you
know pretend it's like no there there's
kind of nuancing there um and yet even
boundaries right are different than
walls uh it was Berne Brown who said
boundaries are the distance at which I
can love both you and
me that's a good way to frame it oh um
boundar is different than W I even had a
a friend lgbtq friend who um said uh
boundaries are different than walls and
that the boundary always has a
door and the door basically has some
right there's some clear communication
around what would it take for us to
start to be able to relate better you
know what would need to change here so
there's right there's a place for
boundaries and such without it though so
um just kind of becoming this this wall
um between us and and others now having
said all that I think this passage
though it's definitely it's a word you
know it's kind of it's nudging us
towards something and I think it's
getting at in essence to to um to be
Christian right is to be kind of filled
um with this forgiving love of God in
Christ and and what that that means is
that we kind of move out into the
world as people very much with right the
heart of God which as Paul talked about
in Christ is very much a heart of
reconciliation I mean this is part of
why we're all here is because of the
grace and goodness and forgiveness of
God right and um now you might be
wondering kind of in light of this text
like what what's the nature of this
reconciliation like is Paul thinking
here of like evangelism you know
spreading the good news the life death
and resurrection of Christ and then
reconciling people to God in that way is
he thinking more along the lines of like
breaking down the Dividing Walls of
hostility like socially you know in his
day kind of Jew Gentile um now it might
be you know male or female or queer or
straight or these binaries that we kind
of set up and then pit against one
another um is it more like interpersonal
conflict right where oh like someone you
know deeply kind of hurts or offs or
wounds or something me or vice versa and
we kind of have to work through that
like what is Paul getting at here and I
think of course the answer is all of
those right that the gospel is about all
of that God's love touches all of that
and and so this calling uh of
reconciliation I think it's a broad one
I think it it touches each and every one
of those things so let me go ahead and
close with kind of a point of
application because as I mentioned I
think this is a really um this is a
timely scripture um for us because of
course um we're kind of merged you know
like it or not in in this sort of um
awful culture
war and I I think um if I were in in a
kind of more well and I used to preach a
lot in more conservative spaces um
theologically and such my my message
would be kind of different and tailored
in that way you know being here it's
different and it even had me kind of
wondering like huh should I even preach
on this theme or not or um and yet it
still felt you know kind of relevant in
a way because I think um in our efforts
right often I think well-intentioned um
to point out Injustice to go to bat for
the marginalized to contend for what we
believe is a better political Way
Forward uh you all know it's very easy
to get so full of
pain so full of anger I mean I don't
know about you I just read social media
I'm just enrage I read the news I'm just
full of Rage I'm just so uh upset I was
about to say the words well just go with
upset so upset um and and what happens
it's so easy in that moment to totally
forget oh that's right I'm an agent of
reconciliation right in essence I
totally forget like that what I say and
how I say it like it really matters um
Christian Author Martin La put it this
way he said now many people who think
they are struggling to forgive are
actually struggling with
pain we keep certain defenses up to
protect ourselves from being hurt again
and we interpret this defense as the
unwillingness or inability to
forgive in essence I think what this
means is that many of us myself included
we have some inner work in healing to do
we have some therapy to attend some
spiritual direction to attend we have
some journaling to engage cheapest
therapy you'll ever get journaling we
have some prayers to pray some silence
to enter into some feelings that we must
allow to be so that the Holy Spirit can
heal that which is injured within us
which in
turn allows us to forgive which in turn
allows us to speak again to those who
have heard us in ways that can actually
possibly if they're willing to do their
part work towards
reconciliation uh as I mentioned I see
this you know all the time on on the
socials um where we it it becomes a
space where when we have not processed
our pain and our grief and our fear in
more healthy Outlets we then turn Le
there to give voice to that rage within
the problem of course as Christians when
we do this is we're no longer acting as
agents of
reconciliation now we're agents of
division ambassadors of
hostility there's a uh a book by Britt
Baron that is on my two- read list I
must Adit I've not yet read this just
little portions like that's free you you
can see on Google books or whatever um
but I really I think I love the title
it's title do you still talk to
Grandma when the problematic people in
our lives are the ones we
love it's written from Baron's
perspective as a post Evangelical queer
woman and uh as the subtitle kind of
indicates right she's naming the trick
is that those people um who hurt us with
with sometimes bigotry um or other
comments and things these are often
people we love
right this isn't just strangers online
that we can usually get over you know um
this this is our parents or our
grandparents or our partners or our
friends or even religious
leaders and and she names like
ultimately though what we want right in
our heart of hearts what we want is for
them to
grow not to be cancelled by an online
mob as she puts
it so what can it look like she asks to
kind of start St striving for justice
without causing new harm or giving up on
the people we
love her book of course is coming from a
a kind of progressive theological
position and political um if you want
kind of another approach this is a
little bit more
bipartisan um but it's it's uh The
Righteous Mind by Jonathan height is an
interesting one uh to to help us kind of
think through this and what I what I
appreciate about these works is they can
really um they can kind of help us
in essence kind of Christians act like
Christians you know um give us handles
on what to do in a time where there's
just a ton of hurt and pain and Division
and it's really easy to forget that in
the bigger picture our calling is
ultimately to be Bridge
Builders and ambassadors of
reconciliation in a world gone mad so
let's remember in every moment we aren't
speaking to mere mortals we're speaking
to children of God offshoots of the
Divine our siblings and let's remember
we aren't just religious people but
we're followers of Jesus Christ and
because of that we are a people on a
mission of
reconciliation in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night that Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held up a
loaf of bread and then he broke it and
he said take it and eat this is my body
it's broken for you then he held up a
cup of wine and he said take it and
drink this is my blood it's shed for you
whenever you eat this bread whenever you
drink this cup remember
me so as we come forward tonight it's
our chance to sense that love sense that
Grace sense that that reconciling heart
of God and then to receive that take
that in and then walk out these doors uh
as those kinds of ambassadors those
kinds of healed people so the way we'll
participate in communion tonight is uh
we'll just go row by row starting here
at the front um we'll just kind of form
a line here in the middle and when one
row finishes the next can go ahead and
get in line uh you should know the red
is wine the white is grape juice uh you
can also just partake whenever and
however you'd like some folks like to
come and kneel at the front some partake
immediately some like to return to their
seats to partake uh but no one will lead
you through the exact moment you can
just do that as you feel led so this is
the table not of the church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so come come you who have much
faith and you who have little you who
have been here often and you who have
not been here long you who have tried to
follow and you who feel like you
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
for
if you guys would like to stand with us
during this last song we're going to
close with come and Tear Down the
Walls um let's just make that our prayer
as we think on process some of the
things that Brett shared with us tonight
and ask God what what are the walls what
are my walls and who are they with and
how can I start taking steps towards
getting rid of some of those
[Music]
come Tear Down the Walls I buil up every
wall I buil up every wall I buil up you
deserve every piece of my heart every of
my heart every piece of My Heart
Lord I am trusting that you are a
faithful father all that you have have
it is
good you're a generous Giver you loves
like no other won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again I am bringing my heart to you with
open Heads closer and closer you're draw
me in as the depths of my heart lay
before you again
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the dep of my heart lay before you
again come Tear Down the Walls of build
up every wall I build up every wall I
build up
you deserve every pece of my heart every
of my heart every Peace In My
Heart
Lord I am trusting you are faithful
father all that you have it is
good you're a generous Giver Your Love
Like No Other would you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again I am bringing my heart to you with
open hands closer and closer you're
drawing me in as the deps of my heart
lay before you
again over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the depths of my
heart you again
[Music]
come Tear Down the Walls I've buil up
every wall I've buil up every wall I've
built up you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are new you'd love for
you to fill out a visitor card um the
small table to my left or you can scan
the QR code and fill out one
online um meetups we can all use more
relational support and spiritual
connection the way we do that here at
the table is through meetups if you're
not yet part of a meet up please scan
the QR code to find one that works for
you
generosity is key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship if the table is
your church home then we invite you to
scan the QR code and give financially or
visit the TBL tx.org
[Music]
as we send you
in um as we send you into the week let
us give you a blessing um so if you can
hold out your hands and a posture to
receive or just open your heart to hear
these
words you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day this is true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
that's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend those same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed and we'll see you back here next
[Music]
week over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the deps of my heart before you
again over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open head
closer and closer you're drawing me in
[Music]